hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Linares
tournament to 2005 uh the last
tournament where Kasparov played is an
active chess player and it's a it's a
game that shows how every position even
um even a very equal one is merely an
opportunity for you to get your opponent
to blunder the problem is you have to
continue making uh precise moves in
equal positions and then if your
opponent is unable to do that you will
uh be able to uh to win the game so
let's check it out kaspar has the white
pieces this is round four uh we've seen
uh how he how he defeated pacovejo in
round three uh so let's uh check it out
because Parov opens with Pawn to D4 we
have Knight to F6 by Adam's uh C for E6
and now Knight the C3 inviting the names
of Indian and that's exactly for what
Adams goes for so we have Bishop to B4
the names of Indian defense uh and queen
to C2 we've already shown the game it
has power play the startups with the
black pieces it was a very nice Victory
two videos ago if you haven't seen it do
check it out quite an amazing game
and okay uh Pawn to D5 this is the Noah
variation and now Pawn to A3 Bishop
captures Queen capture so no messing up
the pawn structure on the queen side and
now Knight the E4 you get to bring your
knight to this beautiful E4 Square very
early on we have Queen back to C2 and
now there are some moves you could
consider like B6 C5 castles many uh good
ideas here Knight to D7 Adams goes for
Pawn to E5
um tries to settle all the attention in
the center very early on C capture Sandy
for Queen captures the queen is very
nicely placed here as the Knight is no
longer able to come to C3 as it's not
there and pawn to F3 challenging this
Knight and here Knight back to D6
interestingly Kasparov had this position
with the black pieces against Vladimir
kramik and he uh won his game against
kramnik
uh in 1998 where he played Knight to F6
but uh in in 2005 Knight the D6 was
considered the strongest reply so this
is what Adams goes for with the
characters on E5 Queen captures and now
Pawn to E4 grabbing the full Center
Knight the C6 and not Knight the E2 with
Bishop to E6 Bishop to F for now
attacking Adams's queen and the Queen
the A5 check and now there is one game
where Queen to C3 was played but here
kaspar plays Knight to C3 and it is now
as of move 14 that we have a completely
new game okay uh Knight to C3 we have
castles Queen Side by Adams and castles
Queen Side by
uh by Gary
uh very very uh interesting position
both players just castling Queen Side
Pawn to F5 striking against uh
kasparov's strong center Bishop capture
son D6 Kasparov gives up his Bishop for
this D6 Knight but in order to mess up
Adam's Pawn structure and open up his
King a little bit Rook captures on D6
with Rook captures and d6c captures and
now Bishop to B5 this is August power
develops the bishop and now the Rook can
also get into the game via the D1 Square
maybe the E1 square if the position
opens up here or maybe even King will go
to B1 and then the Rook can come to C1
so Knights the D4 and this is a very uh
tricky move because part of played
Bishop to B5 of course knowing that
atoms can just play Knight to D for
attacking his Queen and Bishop and B5 uh
but it's maybe not the most precise way
to go about things because it really
forces what happens next and I believe
this is what kasparo was hoping for
Knight the D4 attacks the queen and the
bishop and now Queen to D3 and defends
the bishop on B5 Adam's captors Knight
captures Knight captures now going after
the D6 pawn and there's no good way to
defend the pawn as the Knight will be
able to to grab it with check so just F
captures an E4 and this is the most
precise way to play this queen captures
on D6 and now comes Queen captures on B5
a trading Bishop for Knight here the
problem is you cannot uh defend this if
you play a queen to B6 or something like
that even Knight captures an A7 with
check is possible and after Queen
capture so you will play Queen captures
and E6 with check and even grab the E4
pawn and you're just gonna be down two
Pawns of course this will be completely
winning for for Kasparov so instead
after Queen captures on D6 we have a
trade here Queen capture Sun B5 Queen
captures an E6 with check King to B8 and
now Queen captures on e4 and now it's a
little bit better as you are only down
one Pawn but still down one pawn queen
and Rooks um still in the game should be
able to hold this to a draw so Rook the
E8 you could also go Rook the seat with
check but it's not really anything
special so Rook d8 attacks the White
Queen Queen Death for check King to A8
and now King the B1 getting the King off
of that C file so you don't have to
worry about any nasty checks and now
Adams goes Pawn to G5 he does have a two
to three disadvantage on the king side
and he wants to get he spawns the the
favorable squares so Queen to F7 puts
pressure on the H7 Pawn H6 now and
Kasparov of course uh wants to break
this up by playing Pawn to H4 we have A6
creating some uh breathing room for the
black king and now H captures H captures
and queen to F6
uh putting uh putting pressure on the G5
Pawn for the moment it's defended by the
queen uh but you have to be careful
where you put the queen and the problem
is if you play something like Rook to E2
to put constant pressure on that beat
you upon you just to very easily lose
just Rook day trade with check and
there's not much you can do like King
day seven Queen to D4 check now you uh
either play B7 and then you run into all
sorts of uh checkmating ideas or you
play Queen to B6 and now just a nice
Rook d8 to check uh ends the game you
have to capture and you blunder your
queen on B6 so instead Queen to D3 check
by Adam's King to A1 and now just Queen
to D2 putting a little pressure on that
the G2 Pawn also defending the G5 pawn
and of course notice that if you capture
the G5 Pawn will be defended so it's not
easy for Kasparov to make progress here
he tries a queen to F7 just making some
precise moves uh maybe Adams puts his
Rook on a weird Square Rook to E5 and
okay Queen to C7 again puts pressure on
The Rook rug back to E8 we have Queen to
F7 again puts pressure on the rook and
Rook the E5 atoms obviously very happy
with the draw here he is down a pawn uh
Queen to F6 again puts pressure on The
Rook Rook back to E8 and here kaspar
plays G4 he says all right let's get rid
of that weakness on G2 but now you have
a weakness on F3 so King the A7 the king
will be a little bit safer there you
don't have to worry about any uh
immediate checks along the back rank if
the if the Rook ever moves from the back
Rank and the queen to F5 by Kasparov uh
we have King the A8 uh items just
repeats the position says he's very
happy with the draw here King the B1 we
have rooked the d8 and now Rook the C1
notice that atoms can always trade
Queens if he wants to uh but he prefers
his chances with the Queens on the board
so Rook could be five chases away the
queen and Kasparov goes Queen E4 we have
King to A7 again now Rook to C3 maybe
even with some ideas of Shifting The
Rook to B3 and putting pressure on that
B7 Pawn although you have to be very
very careful uh when doing this with
Queen D1 Chuck King the A2 now Queen
back to D2 Adams not very impressed with
uh kasparov's attempts we have rooked
the C2 goes after the queen queen to D3
and now cause power says all right you
we can trade but of course I'm not gonna
trade here and then just allow your Rook
to put pressure on my F3 Pawn he plays
Rook the E2 he says alright if you want
to trade you can trade but if you trade
then I capture with the F Pawn and then
I start pushing my past E Pawn and with
to the black king so far away from the
action it will be uh it will be fairly
easy to push this Pawn so instead we've
Rook the D4 uh Adam's trying to get gas
part of the trade on D3 and kaspar just
moves the queen to E3 says Nope not
happening uh and Adam's Place Pawn to A5
if he can get his Pawn to A4 that will
uh severely limit the the movements of
the black king plus you will always have
Queen to B3 check and basically you will
always have a draw so Rook the E1 uh
King to A6 and now uh Adams by playing
King to A6 is offering the G5 Pawn for
the F3 pawn and it's not a bad deal for
Kasparov uh for one he does get a pass
Pawn on the king side so Queen captures
on G5 we have Queen captures and F3 and
now Queen to G6 with check and the like
I've mentioned in the beginning of the
video uh every equal position is merely
an opportunity for your opponent to make
a mistake and that is what of course
Kasparov is hoping for he played Queen
to B6 and Adams has the play Pawn to B6
it's not a move you want to make because
you open up your king to all sorts of
attacks because as long as the pawn is
on B7 the seventh rank is sort of
protected from checks once you push it
here it does appear your king will be a
bit more vulnerable
uh but let's say the game would continue
Queen to G8 and now uh What uh what do
you play of course you're not gonna
allow white to start checking you can
trade Queens here let's say captures
captures uh Rook to G1 prepares to push
the fast Pawn Rook G5 stops the pawn and
this will be enough of course for black
to achieve a draw however after Queen to
G6 check Adams played King to A7 which
appears to be even more safe but the
problem is the position is completely
winning forecast part of now but it's
not easy to to spot y so feel free to
pause the video and this is only the
first pause the video moments in this
video uh while I give you a couple of
seconds and try to find the only idea
that wins the game for Kasparov while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
weakness on A5 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
the E5 that's the that's the move that
wins the game the problem is uh you can
see that the G4 Pawn is hanging if you
just Advance the pawn to G5 this is
insufficient just Queen to D5 with check
and after King to B1 Rook G4 and now you
will not be able to save this pawn and
the A5 Pawn is nicely defended uh sort
of what the atoms was hoping for however
Kasparov plays the precise Rook to E5
and there's just no defense now the the
E A5 Pawn is attacked uh he does go for
Rook to A4 the problem is if you go
Queen G4 uh then you just run into
trouble root captures on A5 checking the
B8 and now it's uh it's a force
checkmating sequence Queen T8 check
working to C7 Rook the C5 with checking
to B6 Queen to B5 check King A7 and now
Queen to A5 check steals the deal King
B8 Queen to C7 checking A7 and now of
course the A5 will be Checkmate so
instead after rookie 5 Rook the A4 was
played by Adams this is the only move
that prolongs the game as the pawn is
defended on A5 but now comes
the very nasty Queen to H5 putting more
pressure on that A5 pawn and moving the
queen away from the G file so now
casparov can even start advancing his
past the G pawn and uh it's not easy for
the for the black queen to deliver any
checks because D5 is guarded and F7 is
guarded by the White Queen so here B6 is
played and now again a very very tricky
position only one moved
forcefully win the game for Kasparov not
an easy one to spot feel free to pause
the video and win the game for for Gary
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not resorting to
any any silly checks and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to E8 that's how you do it you
shift the queen to a more active
position where now you are ready to
deliver some deadly checks but you do it
with tempo as the rook and A4 is hanging
so congratulations to everyone who
spotted that and now the problem is you
can pick up the pawn but if you do this
then the roof is so far away from the
action uh the the black king will not
survive this rookie 7 checking A6 Queen
to C8 with the check now there's really
not much to do you have to go to B5 now
Rook to E5 with Chair King to A4 and now
Queen to see to check the black king is
out of squares you have to block and
this will now be Checkmate so of course
after Queen to E8 Adam stride Rook to C4
in order to be able to bring the Rook uh
back to the seventh rank or eighth rank
depends on how casparo continues
checking but now Pawn to G5 so all of
this was in order to uh save the
opponent on G4 and start advancing and
now it's a pass pawn and if you cannot
start checking the white king that means
that pawn is Unstoppable so Rook the C7
uh getting the Rook to help out with the
defense of the king also you cover the
G7 square but now Queen to E6 by
Kasparov we have Ponte A4 going for uh
that Queen to B3 check for the moment
it's impossible but that's why Kasparov
put the queen on E6 uh Rook to E4 now
goes after the A4 pawn and queen to D1
uh this is how Adam defends the pawn but
now kasparo just plays Rook to D Rook to
B for the the most precise move possible
and it was in this position animal 54
that Michael Adams resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the the B6 Pawn is hanging and there's
no way to to do anything here if you try
something like Rook to B7 yes you defend
the pawn but now just Queen to C4 and
the
uh the A4 Pawn uh will uh will fall or
reply B5 then the B5 Pawn will fall uh
black has no compensation here and if
you don't play that what else is there
you could play something like Queen to
G1 okay you could defend the pawn this
way uh but not just Rook captures on A4
and you get checkmated very quickly
Queen B7 Queen D4 or D5 with check
doesn't really matter and after okay you
go here it's a nice Checkmate but if you
go to C8 then Queen the E8 with the
check King to B7 and now again Queen to
A8 will be Checkmate so very nicely done
by kasparo winning his second game in a
row so winning round around three and
four and uh you've seen how uh uh it's
an equal position but it's always uh
it's always a pawn up so you have to be
very careful and here by by giving this
check he uh give Adams an opportunity to
make a mistake in in a sort of a
position that that is possible to hold
but you have to play the nasty looking
B6 so also something that you can take
from the game and maybe try to employ in
your own games don't don't always go for
the more aesthetically pleasing movie it
kind of seems like you keep a better
position but the B6 was was the move
that would probably save Adams the game
he would still have to fight for it but
he would he would definitely have
chances uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it maybe you can
take something from this and like I said
employed in your in your own games or if
not just enjoy a nice Victory bike as
part of in his last tournament as an
active player I would like to wish a
very happy birthday to Jules and I would
like to thank Bojo Kevin Frazier debacus
and see this for trade for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day